christina can you hear me
yes
can you add me back on
[Music]
how so as a co-host
oh of course yes um would you mind
unmuting the tv as well
it's the computer by the tv
yes i will thank you
okay
yeah
see how this goes
hmm
[Music]
judy are you ready
hello
yes i was asked on mute this is jerry
kanerk here yeah jerry i'll get to i'm
going to open here in just a second no
problem thanks
all right it is now uh 1 p.m and we're
going to open the hearing on house spill
272 relative to the late sale of hemp
products containing cbd
i'll ask representative canuck is the
prime sponsor and we'll ask him to come
forward and introduce himself and speak
to the bill
okay thank you very much can everybody
hear me okay we can welcome to the una
thank you very much so yes uh this ball
i should introduce myself i am
representative jerry connerk i represent
carol county district 3. i also serve as
the chair of the new hampshire
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board and i'm also a retired physician
now the issue is that there was a really
rapidly expanding market for cbd
containing products you see them all
over the place gas stations and
everywhere but the problem is that cbd
products are unregulated
and this market's a little reminiscent
of snake oil salesman of old
now cbd is one of the active components
in cannabis it's not so psychoactive
like thc but it does have
pharmacological effects it's currently
not regulated at the state level and
there's only minimal regulation at the
federal level
the major problem for a consumer who
wants to buy cbd is that there's no
requirements for testing or labeling the
product
um in the past some random testing of
cbd products has been done that
demonstrates gross inaccuracies from the
concentration of cbd from what was
stated on the label sometimes with
essentially no cbd in their product at
all contamination of their product with
pesticides and heavy metals and mold can
occur and will not be known to the
consumer if the product is not tested so
this bill seeks to regulate cbd products
for retail sale
with the goal of consumer protection and
safety by ensuring the accurate label of
the contents of the product and a
product free of contaminants along with
appropriate warning labels particularly
with regard to pregnancy lactation and
use in children
a certificate of analysis would be on
the label or traceable from the label
and the testing of labeling requirements
are modeled on the product testing that
we do in the therapeutic cannabis
program also from trade organization
recommendations and we also modeled some
of this after vermont law
now this product is a this bill is a
product of the 2019 hemp study
legislative committee on which i served
with representatives pearl and bixby the
2018 farm bill removes him from the de
schedule one where cannabis resides and
allows sale of him products but the thc
content cannot exceed 0.3 percent in
order to be compliant
the fda does allow sale of products
including oil as long as it is not added
to food or sold with a health claim but
the fda doesn't really regulate cbd or
label
so though the fda prohibits the addition
of cbd to food on a federal level a
state can override that if desired but
there cannot be any transport across
state lines of food products with cbd
added
foods containing cbd should be labeled
because a consumer should have the right
to know how much cbd they are consuming
in a food or drink to allow them to
consume what they perceive as a
therapeutic dose while avoiding
unintentional overdose
i introduced this bill last year as
hb1581 in in the commerce and consumer
affairs committee
and in the original version of the bill
i split the work between dhhs and damf
but it soon became abundantly clear that
damf did not really want anything to do
with it
and we couldn't work out the kinks very
well and so it was sent to interim study
and then in the fall recommended for
future legislation with the revisions
that i had worked on uh to make the bill
a little cleaner
when i rewrote the bill this year i cut
out dams and put it entirely in dhhs
which is where it actually fits better
because it has to do with a
pharmacologically active compound and
cbd is added to food so food safety
which is in dhhs gets involved
i sent all of you a link to the bill
which you of course have but also an
amendment
and i should say i submitted this way
back in september it was very slow
getting out the final version which
didn't come out until december 27
um and the there still are a few
grammatical errors and a few minor input
from stakeholders that developed after
the lsr sign off
so for ease of understanding the
drafting attorney structured the
amendment as a replacement of the two
sections so i gave in what i sent to you
a roadmap how you can toggle back and
forth between the bill and the amendment
so that you can follow it easily because
i know it can often be a bit confusing
and i gave it to you a few days ago so
you could look at it
now i don't want to go through every
single bit of it but just to go over
that in the first part of the bill
uh it simply talks about the issues of
um
you know the hemp and food and so on and
so forth and then in the
uh and this in the testing how the
testing is uh the testing needs to be
done and how testing lab laboratories
are approved and then the amendment is
where we go to cover all the labeling
issues because there were a few things
that changed there and then back to the
bill and i gave the line numbers for
that which covers the
registration fees and rule making
um
if people want i can go over those lines
right now but well maybe i should
beginning through page two line seven is
the bill
then you go to the amendment that's
lines three to twenty five that's the
labeling
then go back to the bill page two line
twenty nine through page three line
eight
again this is all in my testimony that
covers the registration the fees and the
rulemaking then you go back to the
amendment for lines 29 to 31
to authorize an inspector and then
return back to the bill for page 3 line
12 that's the effective date
now many of these changes are rather
minor what it amounts to is for example
in the labeling uh
the oral tincture it was all written as
milligrams of cbd per milliliter which
didn't work for pills and capsules had
to segregate that out there was
correction of a
punctuation mark and point number three
of their product labeling
and then the one real addition
is the addition of a link to the
certificate of analysis using a qr code
or a website from the label
and the last one it was just changing
the word and
a to and because of a grammatical
inconsistency so most of the things on
the amendment are are really just
corrections of
grammatical errors other than the qr
label so the bill pretty much is the the
whole thing now the bottom line is that
you'll also be hearing from
representatives of the cbd industry who
support the bill uh particularly given
the inaction of the fda um in my
testimony i put a segment of what the
national products
association uh submitted last year in
their testimony but i think they're
going to be here but they did state that
they still wish the fda would work on
this and move forward but since they
don't they're supportive of state
standards
so in summary the cbd industry wants
this regulation to project to protect i
should say legitimate companies and we
need this regulation to perfect protect
public health especially with regard to
children and pregnant and lactating
mothers and our citizens deserve this
regulation to know what they're
consuming and be given appropriate
safety and health warnings when they buy
cbd in new hampshire
now a couple things that are some
controversies that i became aware of
only in the last couple of days from
some stakeholders that i wish to just
bring your attention to because you will
hear this testimony
if you do look at the amendment
and you do look at the labeling
you will see that there is a comment in
there
on point three that talks about the fda
advising that during pregnancy and
breastfeeding you avoid using cbd and
that there's no approval for use of cbd
and children except by prescription for
severe seizure disorder
the language that i used about pregnancy
and breastfeeding is taken from the fda
one of the
industry people feels that's a little
too strong the fda approval for houston
children remember that
i also serve as the chair of therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board we have
suspen spent a substantial amount of the
last year working on the question of
any cannabis in
children
in pregnancy and lactation and we've
covered that and come up with our
recommendations because there is another
bill going through that has to do with
uh warning signs for that even in
therapeutic cannabis
so this simply echoes and mirrors that
one of the other concerns
um
that was brought up by one of the uh
advocates or for the uh not advocate
lobbyists for the national industry
is a disagreement about whether or not
food
that contains cbd can cross state lines
my understanding is that you still
cannot cross state lines with food which
is why in the first page it says that
any food any food product that contains
cbd must be formulated within the state
you can move cbd oil across state lines
but not food is my understanding we do
have colleen smith from department of
health and human services food
safety who will be able to clarify that
for us
and the last thing is i got a note an
email from another stakeholder
suggesting we put in language saying
that the lab
that does the measurements would be an
iso iec
17025 accredited lab
um actually in the hemp study committee
we did hear from a lab that was
accredited from maine about how they do
theirs
that was pretty straightforward i should
note that in the therapeutic cannabis
statutory language rsa 126x
there is nothing in there about the
needing to have that particular
certification it is understood that it
would be a certified lab and i would
assume that if this program goes forward
since it is in dhhs
that the approval of the lab which has
to be done by dhhs would follow very
much the same rules they would again use
an accredited lab
because there is a problem with
fly-by-night labs they do need to be an
accredited lab
so it was too late to put the language
in i'm not sure we need it we don't have
it in therapeutic cannabis and i think
we can trust dhhs that they will use an
accredited lab so that can be taken care
of in rulemaking i think i don't need to
go any further except to be available to
ask you for you to ask me questions
thank you
thank you representative for your
presentation very thorough
all right so i know this bill is a
little bit complex for some
do uh does anybody have any questions
you do all right representative mohler
i'll start with you thank you
sir thank you for coming in today to
testify and thank you for taking my
question a question i did have is that i
see that there is a registration fee of
100 per product and that registration
fee gets
assessed every year can you tell me what
that where you came up with that hundred
dollars or what it will be used
yes
that fee is to try to make the program
self-sustaining
the model that after some of the other
registration things that i know you have
in environment and agriculture because
actually it was a
fact uh there's representative bixby and
i were down there working together with
the drafting attorney last year on this
um or year before or whatever to try to
get some language and at that point we
said 75 we up to 200 and made sure it
was per product not per company and the
idea is it's that money which will be
able to fund the position for the
inspector um and the program itself it
will take a little time to get it off
the ground but the idea is to make this
self-sustaining as much as we can
turn my mic back on thank you uh
representative aaron did you have a
question
yes sure um thank you very much and
thank you representative for uh for
coming in
and presenting this
um my question is um
what is
do you have an idea of what this is
going to cost any an average producer
for testing
i mean they've gotta they've got to do
this
testing
and
i'm just trying to get an idea of what
it's gonna cost uh you know the
producers of these products
and how often do they have to test them
um thank you very much for that question
basically it would be each each lot or
each batch that which would be tested um
and so
as far as the cost actually i'm sorry i
do not know the answer to that question
i will say the following um
these are already rather pricey products
to begin with they are so i don't think
it's going to make a big difference if
you wander in your local health food
store to try to pick up a
perhaps 60
milliliter bottle of cbd oil you're
going to find that it's going to cost
you somewhere around 30 or even 40
dollars so there is a pretty high profit
margin on this already i don't think
this is going to be an enormous problem
and actually any of these producers
should be testing their materials
for toxins heavy metals
and molds and also to be sure that what
they claim they're doing is correct plus
to comply with the fda the uh thc has to
be less than 0.3
so i do not know exactly how much that
will cost them to do that
thank you representative
representative davis did you have your
hand up before or did i okay i'm sorry i
thought i saw that all right uh
representative verville if you can
unmute yourself
yeah thank you uh mr chairman and uh
thank you representative kenner for
taking my question um you were talking
about dosage
and uh and potential overdose so i was
wondering if you could tell us what the
typical adult dose would be
what the size of an overdose for an
adult the average adult would be and if
you have any data on the ld50
okay
actually you know i meant to actually
look that up for you because i
what we the one drug we have actual good
dosage data on
is epidiolex and in epidiolex uh the the
dosage i should say also what is the
toxicity there are a couple of
toxicities one of which is liver
disease and that's why the dose has to
be adjusted a wee bit if somebody has
liver disease um
but the doses are actually in the orders
of hundreds of milligrams i actually
just happened to have it took me a
moment here to get there
um
the yeah the doses are actually in the
order of hundreds of milligrams it's uh
the maintenance dose for a child and
which is the usual person who takes this
for seizure disorder 10 milligrams per
kilograms per day so if you had a 50
kilogram adult you'd be talking about
500 milligrams per day as a normal dose
now the point is that
the the person taking this in a small
amount is likely to take very little you
take a dropper full of a cbd oil which
is what's often recommended it's about
10 mils you may be 20 mils and you might
take that a few times a day the time you
would start worrying about toxicity is
if you have a little bit in your morning
coffee you have some more in your muffin
you have a little more in your afternoon
snack you have some in your beer you
also take a little bit on your own from
your cbd oil you could conceivably begin
to get a little higher um i think it's a
relatively small risk that a person
consuming it would get into the toxic
range but it's not an impossibility and
if you have liver disease the dose has
to be
has to be adjusted down and that person
would be more sensitive to it and that
could be a little bit of a problem
so that's that's really the concern i
actually had
personally some recommendations about
having cbd and food um but i was out
voted by representatives bixby and uh
and pearl and so we did vote to go ahead
and put that in and i'm perfectly
comfortable with as long as it's labeled
so people have some sense what they're
getting
did that answer your question well
enough
yeah uh well a follow-up if i can um so
so we're talking about
an over-the-counter product
so we're not really talking about
uh pharmaceutical dosages is that that's
correct right
yes again i think in the normal dose
that somebody would take
that should be not a problem it would
only be as i said if they
happened to take some on their own from
some cbd oil plus all day long they kept
chowing down on a little bit more in
there as to say in their morning coffee
their muffin their their beer because it
gets added just about anything you darn
well could think of gets cbd added to it
so uh there could conceivably be a
problem particularly if it were a
thinner smaller person if it were a
person with liver disease but it's not
likely that's why that's not an enormous
concern in terms of the toxicity but the
issue is
that's the liver toxicity or some of the
other big toxicities
it can have some other toxicities though
um some of its therapeutic effects
things like potentially some help in
anxiety
uh insomnia but we also know that some
of these drugs in larger doses can cause
anxiety and so we have some difficulty
going back and forth between
not we actually bottom line is we don't
have enough data about some of this to
really know
exactly what kind of long-term issues
there may be with underlying medical
problems such as
psychiatric illness we know that
whole plant cannabis has very distinct
issues and somebody with underlying
psychiatric
problems or
in the developing brain which by the way
is the reason for the warning about
children and also the reason for the
warning about pregnancy and lactation
because we do not have enough data in
those populations
thank you uh representative just one
last question if i could mr chairman
sure follow up yeah thank you so
just going down the line
uh representative kanark you had
indicated that these are high margin uh
products and i was wondering if you
could tell us what the average margin on
these products is and
where you acquired that data
i'm sorry i probably shouldn't have used
the word margin but they it's quite
profitable and i remember that
representative bixby presented some
information to us in our hemp study
committee regarding the profitability on
growing an acre of hemp for fiber versus
for oil and the oil is generates quite a
bit of income
so
it's possible actually uh representative
bixby on your committee may be able to
even answer that question better because
i've forgotten that detail
thank you
but you're right i should not have used
the word margin my error
thank you representative
all right so i've lost my screen there
for a second
okay uh representative murray is our has
her hand raised do you have a question
for representative kenner
i do mr chair thank you for taking my
question thank you for taking my
question representative connerk so i did
have a question with regard to items
that were topical in nature do you have
similar concerns with those or is this
just ingestible
products
it's primarily the ingestibles and the
reason for that is the absorption of the
topicals is relatively poor and i also
need to clarify when you say ingestible
that actually is a little bit um there's
there's a mixed issue
is the primary way you can get rapid
absorption and effective absorption is
through the mucosa that's the lining of
the mouth so you put it under your
tongue and you hold it there for a while
and this applies to just about any
medicine the fastest way to get it in is
inhalation
through either smoking or vaporization
we don't do that with cbd
the second fastest is the
sublingual or belief the tongue root
where it's against the
mucosa if you swallow it
you get what we call a first pass effect
and that is a lot of it is
because the way the digestion works it
goes into the portal vein system goes to
liver and much of it is broken down
before it even gets to the body so we
lose some when we take it orally and the
absorption is likewise slower when it's
taken orally and certainly much less
effective topically it's the least
effective way of getting anything into
your bloodstream there may be some local
effects because it is lipophilic it
likes fat it will transfer through
but there are so maybe some local but
the systemic issues are a great deal
less when it's topical again though it
is important that at least the consumer
might have some idea of just how much
cbd is in it if they want to compare two
different products
thank you very much
you're welcome
all right
uh let's see next we have representative
bixby has his hand up
yes thank you mr chairman for taking my
question thank you representative knurk
um
so
uh
the
reading the bill it looks like the
funding for the inspector and for
getting uh and for running the program
is
going to be coming through the
registration fees but
um i'm wondering
those won't be kind of those won't be
coming in at the outset of the program
and i don't see funding for
getting the program up and running uh
how is that going to work
actually um that is a point which i
we did not address
and i just i just became aware of it in
a conversation with the therapeutic
canvas director about 10 minutes before
this phone call they will be testifying
that they do need some startup money i
do not know how much they would need
it's a relatively small program
so the question would be
whether or not this would need a small
appropriation to go into the budget
i i would anticipate it would not
require very much since it's a modest
number of providers or i mean
companies that do it and a modest number
of products that are actually going to
be
um registered but you're right there
will be a lag time it should be
eventually self-funding but there will
be some startup costs
and i did not see a fiscal note which i
was actually a little surprised about i
thought we would get that from them
and may i have a follow-up mr chair
go ahead
uh so this is actually sort of a
follow-up on uh representative murray's
question um
so uh
even though
the the the potential dosage for through
a topical uh cbd
is um
it is
you get a lot less transferred um
wouldn't we still want to protect
consumers by um ascertaining that
what the producer said was in it was
still in it
yes that's why that would still be
labeled uh all products would be labeled
and um inside in on page 2 line 12 and
13 if it's a product that is not an oral
tincture pill or capsule it's the amount
of milligrams per serving or milligrams
per milliliter so we have some way to
measure that but it is important to
realize as i say this has to do with the
systemic toxicity will be less with the
topicals but this bill would say every
product has to be labeled
okay and uh one more follow-up
yes
uh so
um
you work with the um
the medical marijuana commission also
and i i believe that there are
uh
there's some cbd that is uh
also part of that program and i'm
wondering if there's any chemical
distinction between
the cbd that would be derived from
marijuana versus from hemp
no a cbd is cbd it doesn't matter
because well remember the two plants are
nearly identical i mean they're both the
same uh
they're essentially the same plant it's
just a matter of low thc but the cbd is
the same cannabidiol is cannabidiol
regardless which it came from even if
we're
synthesized
but the therapeutic cannabis program of
course has a very different level of
barriers to getting involved you have to
certify as a patient because of having a
qualifying condition and then you do go
to the uh
atc and you can get
compounds which may be cbd predominant
and that is sometimes and fairly often
used for certain indications within the
therapeutic cannabis program the issue
at this point is you know when i when i
go up route 93 and get off at 104 at the
exit there to drive home back in the
days when i used to go down there uh you
go right into that rest stop or the gas
station and they have big signs for
selling your cbd you can buy cbd just
about everywhere currently and that's
the concern
thank you
by the way there is also a statement in
the bill which which exempts the
therapeutic cannabis program from any of
these regulations which makes sense
because they're a separate program
oh and just the for the question that
you weren't able to answer in terms of
the the relative amounts
for cbd versus fiber
uh the fiber was to
this was two years ago but the fiber was
about 75 dollars per acre and the cbd
was about
750 per acre
right
all right thank you representative
any
oh we have some more hands up do we have
any questions in the room
paying attention to the computer here
all right
representative verville looks like you
have another question
representative verville you're muted
still
i can see you talking but we're not able
to hear you try and muting again
ah there we go sorry yeah had the dub
had the double mute going uh thank you
mr chairman thank you uh representative
kenner um
and and thank you representative bixby i
i understand that you know we got a
selling price per acre but i'm not sure
that that translates into realized
profits uh but my my real question is
do we have data on the last 12 24 or 36
months
of how many people
have been you know either admitted or
treated for overdose or negative effects
from uh consuming too much cbd in new
hampshire
actually no i do not
sorry
okay i do not have any
i'm sorry my my apologies go ahead
represent please sell latency we can't
hear this
i don't have any evidence sorry any data
regarding uh numbers and again some of
these are not going to be necessary
somebody who gets overtly ill
uh the
for example some mild liver dysfunction
would be something you might not know
about until a period of time or may show
up when you get some labs and nobody
would even necessarily know which is why
there's a recommendation if you're going
to take it you would discuss or if
you're taking medication you discuss
this with your primary care provider
we're not talking about overdoses like
opioids it's not something where
somebody's going to stop breathing
there are no cannabinoid receptors in
the brain stem so it does not affect
breathing so that's not really a concern
but there are other medical effects if
you have too much of a medication
including for example it has an
interaction with
statins if you take uh torvastatin or
pravastatin for a high cholesterol
the cbd is metabolized with the same set
of enzymes as is your statin and if you
start taking cbd your statin dose
effectively will go up even though you
haven't changed the dose the blood level
go up and that has significant side
effects so the point is it is
pharmacologically active and but it's
not something where we're talking about
overdoses like opioids or people are
going to drop dead that's not the issue
thank you representative
you're welcome
all right we have uh representative
murray has her hand raised again
representative murray do you have
another question
yes i do thank you mr chair thank you uh
rep knight for taking my question uh
with regard to page two lines one
through four
my question was with
obtaining that certificate of testing
for the pesticides metals solvents etc
if if a purchaser
does not have access to a phone or an
internet is there a document on file at
a point of sale within a retail
establishment that they can get that is
that the intent
actually
that is not part of this bill
the it would be through either a qr code
or a website so i would think that
i may have to confess i didn't start
using qr codes just a couple of years
ago myself but the website would be
there so they could track it down to a
website the rare person who does not
have any excess
whatsoever could certainly ask someone
else for help if they wish to do this
but i think it'd be a little bit more
burdensome on all of the
retail outlets if we ask them to have
all of this on file
all right
representative bixby has his hand
and i guess i don't unless it didn't go
down representative bixby you want to be
recognized again yes i am i audible
yes
okay uh thank you mr chairman for taking
my question um so i just wanted to
uh get a little bit clear of
clarification since some of the
discussion has been
uh
whether the uh having the
um
the dosage and the uh the amount
contained listed
is uh an issue of trying to prevent
overdoses and
my impression was that um that's
that's a smaller part of it than
uh
the fraud prevention end where someone
may be labeling a
vial of cbd as having a lot in it and it
has
uh little or none
and being able to sell it without any
sort of um consequences
yeah is that that is correct
yes that is correct i mean it's really
multiple things it is for consumer
protection that you are actually going
to be able to purchase what you think
you're purchasing because indeed that's
why the um
the product the industries the national
products association likes this because
they want to protect the legitimate
businesses and
get rid of the fly-by-nights that are
just putting out
some oils that don't really have
anything in it the second thing was that
warning for the more susceptible groups
of pregnancy
lactation and kids and the third piece
again the toxicity but as i mentioned to
representative verville it's a very
small issue in terms
that's a much lesser issue in my mind
it's just a piece that's there the risk
of
getting toxicity again it's not an acute
toxicity it'd probably be more of a
chronic toxicity um by taking too much
but i do acknowledge that is the lesser
of all of the things the major is for
consumer protection and protection of
little kids and pregnant women lactating
women more than anything else
thank you representative uh
representative aaron i'll recognize you
for a question yes thank you very much
thank you again uh representative for uh
taking my question
um i'm just a little concerned about um
the costs for the producers especially
when they've been looking at producers
that are
you know smaller in nature
because the registration costs and
testing costs those fees can mount up
pretty quickly
and i just feel like um
you know this might be cost prohibitive
for smaller companies
and smaller producers and i'd like kind
of your uh
your thoughts on that
okay i think actually i know that we
have a couple of people that are from
the industry that are on this call who
plan to testify
and perhaps this better thing would be
to ask them first of all i would presume
that for many of them they probably have
to do the testing for other states as
well so if they are producing
and because some of them are larger if
they are producing they would be able to
the same testing would work for any
number of states
and in terms of registration
i
i i don't know and that's why i would
say let's ask the industry people they
can give you a sense about that one
thank you so much
thank you
all right thank you representatives i
don't see any more hands or any further
questions so we appreciate your uh
testimony
thank you very much
all right next we will call cheryl
murray powell
[Music]
hello good good afternoon my name is
sheryl murray powell esquire i'm a
cannabis agricultural and dietary
supplement attorney i've been in the
industry for about five years now i
am a hemp farmer licensed in two states
as well as i represent as as an attorney
um some of the larger cbd companies in
in the country uh the current largest
retailer in the world um along with a
lot of small players so thank you for
that um question about making sure that
our
requirements are not restrictive with
regards to the smaller participants
um i just wanted to first say thank you
for
all the work that's gone into this bill
it's very clear um the focus on consumer
protection but at the same time creating
a robust market and also thank you for
the opportunity to speak with you today
with regards to this bill
my
largest concern has to do with the
restriction on interstate commerce
interstate commerce is is not regulated
uh by individual states it's not
regulated by the fda it's not regulated
by the usda however
in the most recent interim final rules
from the usda which um they were
produced on the 19th of this month they
did offer up guidance as to how to
handle interstate commerce so um that
guidance is readily available
there is no federal prohibition
on interstate commerce with regards to
cbd and hemp in fact the interpretation
that there is is um
definitely an anomaly when you look at
the interpretation that we've seen
across the country with the other states
so again per the most recent usda
interim final rules they give guidance
on
how to conduct interstate commerce of
hemp and hemp products
also
something to consider is the fact that
federally this issue is is being
discussed the labeling issue um how it's
going to proceed um there's a bill that
i recommend you all take a look at is hr
it is the hemp and hemp derived cbd
consumer protection and market
facilitation act and the intention is
for uh cbd to be and cannabinoid
medicine or cannabinoids i should say to
be regulated like a dietary supplement
and i think that'll clarify a lot of the
questions that we have today and um
that's another reason why i would ask
that section two
he's struck and out where you are
putting a restriction on interstate
commerce which isn't within the
authority of individual states or the
fda or the usda um with regards to our
roadways and our waterways
um so
again when you look at the industry and
we look at the industry you're trying to
create in new hampshire
not all of your participants your
farmers are going to want to grow for
extracts and oil so you would be
restricting your market to local
producers when people are already um
using products from across the country
and um as
as it's been said you can't put
toothpaste back in the tube um it's
already a national um commodity that's
that's sold um usually the language that
states will uh select for this type of
uh restriction or intent is to say any
state that participates in our state has
to
a either have a usda approved plan
or they need to have rules labeling
rules similar to our labeling rules but
other states are not restricting where
participation has to come from only
in-state producers
um really great feedback with regards to
the dosing issue um and as it's been
stated the fda has not given given
guidance on upper control limits and
lower control limits um however um there
is a study that's um being done under
the guidance of the fda it's a valid
care study there are 12 industry
participants um that are doing this real
world evidence study and that will that
is a liver safety study
it is also looking at sleep and it's
also looking at reproduction with
regards to
testicular impacts that study the output
should be produced this quarter and the
fda will take the information from that
and their indication is that they will
use that to have a little bit more
insight for the industry with regards to
dosing as well as
some of the liver concerns that have
been raised today
another point is when with the
disclaimers uh and the warnings i think
it's really important that we warn um
with regards to the items listed um i
would just caution against using
specific specific language and requiring
specific language because again
multi-state operators are getting
different language from different states
and it's an undue burden for them to
have to do separate labels first for all
50 states in in the union so i would say
if the intent is to say um uh have a
warning about the use by pregnant and
lactating women use that type of
language instead of the specific
language um that would have to that may
not mirror what's happening in other
states and would restrict commerce
um great question that was raised with
regards to the topicals
and with regards to the um there's uh
item number or provision number eight
where it talks about manufacture date my
suggestion is that use expiration date
especially if you're um trying to
consider consumer protection um the
manufacturer date won't mean as much to
a consumer as an expiration date would
so
great job thank you representative nerd
for your for sponsoring this bill for
engaging the industry thank you to all
of you present for um your diligent
review and and great questions as far as
how to move this industry forward in a
way that is safe and consumer and uh
protects the consumer
thank you for your testimony do we have
any questions
do we have any hands-free questions
do not see any so uh
oh do we have one
yep all right represented bixby yes i
recognize you for a while thank you for
taking my question uh mr chair and uh
uh
and mr powell um so
in regards to the uh
the interstate commerce uh with food
products
um
the
uh the author of the bill has put in as
the final sentence
if federal law allows interstate
commerce of food products containing cbd
then this paragraph shall be void does
that cover your concerns
yeah i think i think um
with the with it being it because
basically it's being will be implemented
as a void provision so instead of
inserting in my preferred approach would
be not to include it so it doesn't cause
law enforcement confusion because in the
states where we've had
voidable language we've seen where law
enforcement has to therefore put on
their judge hat their their lawyer hat
and do the interpretation in munich at
the municipality level or even at the
individual officer level and that's
where we see people you know maybe
getting arrested on and then having to
have the charges drops having to
hire lawyers when the salesperson the
retailer the manufacturer they're right
but it's a basically a layman's
interpretation of law so i am not really
a fan of avoidable provision like that
based on having reviewed the legislation
across the country
but at this point considering um again
the usda interim final rules that were
just released
and also the h.r 8179
federal bill which has 30 sponsors and
growing i think this is something that
we should look to the federal government
to give us more direction on rather than
include it here and and be
an anomaly amongst the other
sister states
thank you
you're very welcome thank you for the
question do we have any further
questions
all right seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you so much take care
okay next we'll have
colleen smith from hhs
thank you mr chair and thank you members
of the committee for allowing me to
provide information today for the record
my name is colleen smith i'm the
administrator of the food protection
section within the department of health
and human services
while the department is not currently
taking a position on the bill at the
time we'd like to highlight some areas
for your consideration and also ask for
the opportunity to provide some
additional details with a fiscal note
as
was previously stated
currently the u.s food and drug
administration does not allow cbd in
food products and
whereby new hampshire has adopted the
federal food code within its its food
safety regulations cbd derived from hemp
or or any other source is not currently
allowed to be added to food so certainly
the sale of products containing cbd
derived from hemp poses a regulatory
challenge for new hampshire
the well the food code states that
um
any food additive has to be approved and
and because safety of cbd and food has
not been adequately studied or it
currently is not allowed by fda and food
section 2 lines 11 through 14 address
this issue by stating that the
non-pharmaceutical or non-medical
production marketing sale or
distribution of food food additives or
food products that contain hemp or cd
cbd shall not
be prohibited within new hampshire
solely based on the inclusion of hemp or
cbd
and then section 3 further requires that
the addition of cbd to any food product
shall take place in new hampshire
this bill requires the department to
regulate would require the department to
regulate all cbd infused products in the
state and would require the department
to inspect and enforce not only in the
the food retail environments but also in
establishments that traditionally food
inspectors don't
routinely visit such as pet stores vape
shops cbd stores hair salons and spas
and wellness centers and
and doctors offices
so if we this would this
in essence wouldn't create a completely
new program for the department
um we would envision that this program
would be responsible for the creation
and maintain main maintain maintenance
of a registration database for all the
cbd products
inspections would be needed to be
conducted relative to registration of
products containing cbd
and then also
there would need to be enforcement
activities related to the sale of cbd
products that did not have a valid
registration
and then also
there is allowance for the propagation
of rules and consultation with the
department of agriculture markets and
food
we have done some rough estimate
estimates in
personnel cost in annual personnel costs
um also including purchase of vehicles
for inspectors computers workstations
and in a database
so
at a minimum we're estimating it might
be 360 000
a year to stand up this program
it was previously noted there is a
technical issue within the bill
for the funding of the program while the
department has fee granting authority to
charge a 100
registration fee annually there isn't
an appropriation for startup costs
the department also has concerns about
the ability to approve a laboratory
that is doing the
the analysis for the cbd products is
that something the department does not
currently have
the
capacity to do
uh and you know in lieu of fda action to
allow and regulate cbd as an approved
additive hb 272 proposes several
several suggestions to assure the safety
of cbd infused products for new
hampshire residents to do this well and
to protect the residents of new
hampshire appropriate resources must be
available to administer an effective
program
and further consideration must be given
to address the technical challenges
again i thank you for allowing me to
present this information and would be
happy to respond to any questions that
you have
thank you colleen are there any
questions
representative murray
yes mr chair thank you for taking my
question and thank you to director smith
for taking my question as well
so are you indicating that most likely a
third party lab would have to be
contracted to do the testing is that am
i understanding it correct
the way the bill is written it does say
that a third party laboratory would do
the testing but the department would
have to certify or approve that
laboratory
and and
follow up if i may sorry
and
and are you saying that you currently
don't have a mechanism for doing that is
that can i hear a little bit more about
that so the department currently doesn't
have a an approval process for approving
this type of laboratory
okay thank you
thank you colleen would it be possible
for you to provide
the uh the committee with
sort of the highlights of what you
provided us for information some of us
were trying to write it down but i know
there was a lot there you think you
could provide that for us in an email oh
certainly we will provide a copy of the
testimony that would be great thank you
all right representative verville has a
question
thank you uh mr chairman and uh
thank you commissioner for taking the
the question so
excuse me so
how many do we have any feel for how
many products would are currently sold
in new hampshire
that would be registered at a hundred
dollars a product
uh we we do not i um it we don't have a
mechanism currently for tracking that
information just for example i went on a
internet site for a
cbd
[Music]
store and they had over 60 products in
just that store alone and that's just
one size it doesn't account for if
they're offering the same type of
product in multiple sizes
uh follow up for five minutes
yes go ahead
so
so if i have a if i have a product you
know uh virgo's magical cbd
and i'm marketing that in
1 8 16 32 64 128 fluid ounces so i have
multiple
packaging sizes but the product
in the package is the same do i have to
pay 100 to register each one of those
sizes or am i paying the 100
registration fee for the
the particular product that's contained
within
i
would say that we would need more
further clarification on that but i
believe it was mentioned um in previous
testimony that would be
analysis per batch so if those products
were made for multiple batches
they might have to provide that analysis
at least um
with each individual batch
per product
that follow up
yes go ahead
so but my
so i understand providing the analysis
but there's a hundred dollar per product
registration fee in the bill
and so
you know to stand up a three hundred
thousand dollar
um a year program you need at least
three thousand
products just to break even at that
at that level so
it
do we believe that there are currently
3 000 or more
unique products for sale in new
hampshire that would register at a
hundred dollars for a product that that
that really is the question
and and i think right now that's that's
indeterminable and and also we don't
know if any with those registration
project
process would that deter or
or encourage
you know new vendors into new hampshire
thank you i appreciate it thank you mr
chairman
all right next i will recognize the
representative bixby
yes thank you mr chair for taking my
question um
and
uh
i'm trying
okay it i just got caught up in the
discussion that's slipped in mind what i
was
going to focus on here so if you could
come back to me after representative
murray that would be good
all right i can do that
we'll give you a senior moment break
how's that
[Laughter]
all right uh representative murray i'll
recognize you for a question
yes thank you mr chair and thank you
again um
uh to the director for taking my
question would this
legislation also um
address online
or internet sales within the state
um that that's a great question that was
a question that we had discussed in
internally when
at the department level regarding the
bill it because it is um currently
silent um on internet sales and and also
you know recognizing that would present
some
um in
enforcement um
issues not knowing um
where folks are are ordering products
from their home
okay thank you
all right thank you uh representative
bixby
yes i found my question um so uh in
terms of uh credit
giving and doing the accreditation for
the labs that might be um
providing the the analyses uh it was
mentioned um earlier that there is an
iso accreditation project
process that a number of labs have been
certified by the iso
um
and that i was wondering if um using
reference to that would be an
appropriate way to
take care of the certifying labs who
might be
accredited by the state and
and also
whether it make more sense to have that
uh in rulemaking or whether to have that
in the statute
thank you for that question i i think
that would be um maybe a path forward
into addressing that issue but certainly
we would probably want to involve
some of our public health lab staff and
also
consult with the therapeutic cannabis
program
on their laboratory accreditation
procedures on on how maybe we could um
fix um add additional language to to
address that
so so internally so you would prefer to
have that in the uh follow
um so you'd prefer to have that in the
um
statute rather than in rulemaking
unless it was addressed
in the the statute that gave the
department authority within rulemaking
to
establish those laboratory standards
okay thank you
thank you any further questions
seeing none
thank you colleen for coming in and
testifying and i look forward to getting
this an email from you with those facts
you gave in the beginning very helpful
yes we'll provide that thank you
okay next i will recognize kyle turek
from the natural products association
thank you uh can you guys hear me okay
we can
okay great
so thanks again for having me uh just a
little bit about the natural products
association we're the
largest and oldest trade association
representing the entire natural products
industry uh we represent the entire
supply chain from
retailers manufacturers
[Music]
and we have a
strong presence in the state of new
hampshire
a little bit of background on cbd in our
position um
the fda provided it interested persons
with the opportunity to submit comments
about the who's recommendations to
impose international manufacturing and
distribution restrictions
these comments were
were considered in preparing the united
states's
position on these proposals for a
meeting uh at the u.n
regarding cbd preparations the who and
its expert committee prepared a health
hazard evaluation
and
cbd while founding cannabis and cannabis
resin is not found to have the same
psychoactive properties and results in
no potential use for abuse and protect
potential to produce dependency
now what we've seen
at the federal level
and this is one of the reasons why we
support
the bill
is that across the country the states
are recognizing the gap that's been left
by the fda
and are developing their own regulatory
standards currently right now there are
about 21 states throughout the country
that have introduced or passed similar
legislation to what's being considered
today
and while uh mpa's opinion is that we'd
like to see the fda establish
one uniform national standard we
understand that
legislators like yourselves need to take
responsibility of this public health
issue and establish a regulatory
framework for manufacturers
um and that would include establishing a
safe daily level of consumption
inspecting facilities testing products
for
uh impurities such as lead and
pesticides as well as thc
um over the last several years over 3
000 products have come to the market
without a consistent approach um by the
fda
and
about a year and a half ago we
commissioned a poll
that found
a large number of americans currently
believe that the fda
is overdue in establishing safety
standards and unfortunately 41 of those
surveyed assume that the fda has already
taken that responsibility and
established safety standards
um
and as i've mentioned before
because the fda has not determined that
cbd is generally recognized that's as
safe
um we support uh elements to the bill
that i have you know um
would
call for testing products for heavy
metals pesticides and thc
um currently the usda
has about 37
testing laboratories throughout the
country
and unfortunately
the volume of hemp produced
and the lack of facilities has led to an
industry-wide concern
[Music]
this is part of the reason why we've
advocated at the federal level for
providing an independent verification
program
for product analysis
we would work with the university of
mississippi to randomly select a
thousand products that purport to
contain cbd and these products would be
tested using known standards for their
content impurities
um
you know pro when it comes to product
labeling despite the fact that the
market for cbd
has grown significantly the fda and ftc
have done little enforcement actions on
these products
um
unfortunately a lot of their enforcement
actions have been uh what we would
consider low-hanging fruit which
comes from unsupported health claims and
this is
another reason as to why we support the
labeling elements to this bill
if you were to look at what's being done
internationally in the united united
kingdom um
they've established a series of
requirements including a recommended
daily dose ensuring that amounts
consume do not exceed 70 milligrams for
a healthy adult
and they also have included
uh product labeling requirements
for
minors as well as
pregnant women
and you know that's kind of
where mpa's position is on this we
strongly urge you guys to support this
piece of legislation and move it forward
because as the leading trade association
for natural products and dietary
supplements what we've seen is a
marketplace that
has allowed for
unscrupulous actors to enter the
marketplace and put consumers at harm
all right thank you mr turk any
questions from any of the members of the
committee
thank you appreciate you coming in
addressing the committee
thank you
do we uh do we have anyone else from the
public that would like to testify on
this bill
if you do please raise your hand
all right seeing none
i will i'm going to close this bill and
our next bill will be house bill 318
that we will take up at 2 15.
hmm
oh
here
versus um
um
so she's a sponsor
yes
uh
sponsorship
who were
so
foreign
uh
so
okay it is 2 15 i'm going to
open up house bill 318
an act proclaiming the daring jumping
spider to be the state spider of new
hampshire
and i would like to recognize
representative mcgee
to introduce the bill
thank you chairman pearl it's very nice
to be with you today
and thank you to the rest of the members
of environment and ag
for this hearing i'm here to speak to
you on hb 318 for the official status of
the daring jumping spider as the state's
the state spider of new hampshire
i just wanted to say that
this bill was introduced on behalf of my
constituents in the hollis primary
school
and the bill was first brought to me by
environmental science teacher mrs happy
who is going to speak after me
and before the expert witnesses from
team spider that you'll be hearing today
as i reviewed rsa3 on state symbols and
emblems i realized that the purple lilac
and the white potato may not be
everyone's favorite flower or vegetable
but someone at some point found the
significance of these symbols to be
applicable and important and significant
in new hampshire and so they brought
them to the legislature for
consideration of symbolic to the state
in terms of giving them official status
as i learned more about the process that
these third graders
the witnesses you will be hearing from
today are eight years old
the process that they underwent to
determine which spider would be the
appropriate spider to be a state spider
in new hampshire
i think they have done their due
diligence that would make some of us
feel bad that we don't do our homework
as well as they do they're quite
impressive so
um
so i think you know they
have have their arguments together
[Music]
and
i think mrs happy and team spider
the team spider folks that are here that
i just want to give you their names i'm
sure she'll introduce them again are
chloe
eva nora and jeffrey
and they are the study committee if you
will
who did the research on behalf of this
bill and in this strange coveted year um
this has come to mean a great deal to
them and so i think they'll be
explaining that story to you as we go
so we're here today to present evidence
to nominate the daring jumping spider
which is also known as phytipus
that's its official name which would
also be in the statute if it if it gains
uh
state spider status some of these are
tongue twisters um and we ask that you
support this bipartisan bill and let it
come to the house for a vote so i'm
going to turn the presentation over to
mrs happy yes that is her real name
unless you have questions for me
all right thank you representative mcgee
are there any questions at this point
do not see any all right so yes if mrs
happy would like to come up we'd be
happy to have her
is happy are you able to uh unmute and
talk to us
sorry sorry about that
all right your volume
yeah um
we're just using a different zoom
platform that i'm used to teaching my
students with but let's start over
that's fine
all right so my name is tara happy and
thank you chairman pearl and members of
the environment and agriculture
committee for hearing us today
i'm the environmental science teacher
here at hollis primary school and i
teach year-round outdoor education to
kindergarten through third graders here
in hollis and this year as a result of
an online new hampshire fish and game
workshop that i attended i created a
week-long spider unit for third graders
i had found that after i had began to
learn more about spiders and all the
amazing things they can do that i was
sincerely less afraid of them i'm not a
fan of spiders
but as i went through this program i i
began to appreciate them and so knowing
that spiders are a common fear of
children i hope that with some positive
education on the topic i could do the
same for my students and eliminate a
learned fear that so many of us have
and so this started off just as an
honest effort to make children more
comfortable with spiders but what i
didn't
happen was a school-wide movement to
elect a new hampshire state spider
after learning how important spiders are
to our world the students were a little
shocked to learn that such an important
species wasn't recognized with a state
symbol and the kids instantly declared
that it wasn't fair and spiders deserve
to be loved just as anyone else
so the kids told me that small and scary
things are still special to our world
and it was like watching a crowd unravel
as they began to cheer on the underdog
of a losing football game i really had
to admire the determination to help out
this spider in general so off we went
with the idea
we researched some spiders we checked
with two game in a local nature center
to make sure that we had all of the most
important species represented in our
election and then our election began we
had the web spinning spiders versus the
hunter spiders
and there were spider speeches from our
four candidates some very heated spider
debates placed in our formal forest
classroom but in the end a hunting
spider the daring jumping spider won
some students were happy and some were
sad but we all agreed to back up our
winning spider candidate
we felt that this spider represented the
spirit of new hampshire
be brave and take bumps but hey leave a
web as you fly through the air just in
case be tough and survive these long
hard winters so you can eventually enjoy
the warmer weather and be adventurous
hunt and explore and don't just sit in
one place and wait for food to come to
you go get it
so all i know is that i started off with
the class yelling ew
and by the end of the week i had lined
them up in our garden and they were
literally waiting in line to hold a
little black spider with their bare
hands
so it's really all about how something
is presented and today our students are
going to explain how and why they love
this little daring jump rider thank you
so much for your time with us i know
that you guys are busy and we really
appreciate taking the time out to listen
to our students so
if there's any questions
for me i can turn it over to team spider
sure are
all of the kids together on one zoom or
will they be coming up individually um
they all have their own computers were
spread out in this whole area so they
should all be in their own on on their
own screens
okay
uh do you have any particular order
you'd like me to call them or just go
through um actually chloe is gonna start
us off
i'll tell you what if if you'd like why
don't you have them uh you just announce
them and have them come up in the order
that you'd like how's that
okay would you okay so you want to come
over to my screen chloe okay come on
over kiddo thank you
this happy screens oh there we go
but we had it for a sec
thank you chairman pearl and the rest of
the environmental and agricultural
committee hi my name is chloe and we are
here from hollis primary school and we
are here to prove our point on why we
think the daring jumping spider should
be new hampshire state spider
our environmental science teacher mrs
happy discovered that new hampshire does
not have a state spider yet
and
we
and we all think we should mrs happy
talk to some state representatives and
they thought it would be a good idea too
we spent a lot of time learning about
spiders and we even went outside in the
woods and gardens to look for spiders we
hunted for spiders spider webs and any
traces of spiders we could find
we found three in my class and i held
one on a stick and now eva will tell you
more of the story
thank you chairman
[Music]
thank you chairman pearl in the
environment and agriculture committee
my name's eva and i think that the
daring jumping spider should be the new
hampshire state spider
in my class we went outside to a garden
and looked for spiders too unfortunately
we didn't find any but we did
find some spider webs miss happy our
teacher went to every class and had them
vote on which spider they wanted
every student
had the choice between four spiders
we got to see a slideshow of the four
choices
every class in the whole school voted
and the daring jumping spider had the
most votes
everyone at hps is excited to see if the
daring jumping spider will become the
new hampshire state spider
we pick the new hampshire state spider
and we hope you will too and now you'll
hear from my friend nora
thank you chairman pearl and the rest of
the committee my name is nora lane
i am eight years old and in third grade
at holland's primary school one of my
favorite classes is environmental
science with mrs happy we've spent a lot
of time this school year learning about
spiders even finding some in our school
gardens my friends got to hold them
mrs happy taught us
about how spiders are such an important
part of the wildlife in new hampshire
new hampshire like most other states
mislists many insects among their state
symbols
these include honeybees butterflies
dragonflies and ladybugs however south
carolina is the only state to recognize
a spider as a state symbol it's the
carolina wolf spider
in addition to a state insect
interestingly this was the results of
the efforts of a third grader now new
hampshire third graders like me want to
continue to build awareness of how
valuable spiders are and select one type
that is a good fit for state
a lot of people i know don't like
spiders
some people think they're scary ugly and
annoying
this year i learned that spiders are
really helpful to our environment this
is because they eat mosquitoes flies and
bugs and other insects we might
encounter when we spend time outside
they help keep those population balanced
which is for our gardens in the inside
of our homes if we didn't have spiders
it would just
change and the number of household cats
could skyrocket we wouldn't want that
would we if new hampshire is nine state
spiders an official beverage the state
dog estate insects and nine state songs
and spiders should not be left out even
though spiders might be small and look
different from other creatures they are
really mighty and each one has its own
special talents and characteristics
for new hampshire a great choice is the
jumping spider they're generally
friendly enjoy spending time in the
garden and they have the super power
they can jump 20 to 50 times their own
body size of all the spiders in new
hampshire the jumping spiders leaps and
bounds above the rest jeffrey can tell
you more about the daring jumping spider
good afternoon
i'd like to thank chairman pearl and the
environmental committee for letting us
to be here today to speak on behalf of
our school
i think we should have the daring
jumping spider as our state spider
because of the following reasons
one he's cute and colorful
like new hampshire's trees in autumn
two
daring jumping spiders create parachutes
when they are young so they can fly away
to a new home
they like to be free just like the
citizens of new hampshire believe in
freedom
three
daring dumpling spiders are very
resilient to the cold
they survive new hampshire's winter just
like we survive our cold climates
four we can also make some money to
benefit from new hampshire there could
be state spider key chains refrigerator
magnets
t-shirts and maybe even put our hearing
jumping spider on our on our new
hampshire license plate
we have a state vegetable and i don't
really like vegetables so i think we
should have a steak spider to even it
out a bit
thank you for taking our daring jumping
spider into consideration thank you for
your time
now my principal mrs is vicky will have
a turn
hi good afternoon my name is mrs vicki
i'm the principal here at hollis primary
school um and i'm actually just wiping
away tears because i'm just so very
proud of what they've done here today
and i didn't hear what they were going
to say first so
this is just fantastic for me um so
chairman pearl and the committee thank
you so much for hearing them today this
is such an exciting experience for them
um i really want to thank you for taking
the time to listen to them they have
worked so hard to nominate this state
spider i can attest to the hard work and
research and excitement that they've had
in this project um they haven't spoken
the volumes of work that has gone into
this project
we are very unique here in hollis we are
so lucky to have mrs happy as
environmental science it's a special in
our school we are a small community and
we are rural and we love our environment
around us and the kids are so lucky to
experience that every day
and
mrs happy brings out the best in that so
they they just get these wonderful
experiences that we're so happy to be
able to provide for them
um they have researched these spiders
they have presented their findings uh
our pre-k to third grade students voted
on this and um everybody had a voice in
it
when we actually got to the final daring
jumping spider and when i announced it
over the speaker i could hear the cheers
in the building that they were excited
that daring jumping spider won
as you all know our school year just
hasn't been the same although we are in
person learning our third graders have
had to look for other options for
excitement um
activities such as this
we have focused on kindness and
compassion through our choose love
lessons and how we support and love
everyone regardless
our students are supporting a small and
somewhat scary
creature and it's a really big deal
because it shows just that
and they understand that all living
things have a purpose
i urge you to show these students that
their hard work their lessons learned
their compassion and understanding
and their reflection and their ability
to change
doesn't go unnoticed i hope that you can
support them thank you so much for
listening to them
they are super excited and i can't wait
to share
with our community and everybody with
the results actually
are so i am so proud of them
you all did a wonderful job today thank
you all so much for hearing us um my
best regards thank you
well thank you all that was quite a
presentation
i learned a few things about the jumping
spider that i did not know as i expect
we all did
so um i'll open it up i guess at this
point to see if there's any questions of
the kids and uh if you can
pitch the questions and i guess if
you've got want to bring with the kids
on and answer them yourself i'll leave
that up to you so uh representative
aaron i'll recognize you for a question
yes thank you very much and um
i absolutely
i'm so excited for the work that these
kids put forth obviously
in this presentation
i'm interested to know from each of the
children that spoke
what is their favorite
fact about this particular spider just
one fact from each of them
all right there they're headed over
um
so my favorite fact about the during
jumping spider is that its dumping
spider doesn't actually
spin webs it jumps to hunt for its food
my favorite fact about the daring
jumping spider is that in the winter it
doesn't just curl up and die it stays
strong and it survives the winter
my favorite fact about the daring
jumping spider is that he can jump very
very very long for his size
my favorite fact about the jarring
jumping spider is that it can make a
parachute
out of its web and then fly away
those are all awesome
thank you so much that was wonderful all
right i will recognize uh rep perez for
a question
actually it's not a question but i want
to say
thank you to mrs happy and all the
students from the third grade and hollis
um i really appreciate everything that i
learned about the spider
um
i was scared about spiders before but um
when i started learning about this
spider um yeah i like the spider so i
would like to say thank you to the
teachers and for the schools who let the
students work in this project it was
really really amazing all the work that
they did
and then
teach us about the spider
all right i will recognize uh
representative uh sorry drew blank real
quick stapleton sorry
hi um thank you for that wonderful
presentation and for the background
information
especially the pictures of the spider
with the pdf attachments to the news to
the email
and i thought that was really a nice
addition to the presentation so i
encourage all the members to look at
that email with the pdf attachment
picturing the spider and thank you very
much for that nice work
representative hamola
thank you very much to the third grade
class of hollis primary i wanted to ask
mrs happy
if this was a project that was done by
the entire third grade i'm sorry i
couldn't hear it very clearly at the
beginning or just a one class of that
and then i also wanted to comment and
say that i
learned a lot i really appreciate all
the work that you did nora your mom was
telling me about how hard your whole
class worked in this and i just want to
say congratulations i'm just so glad
you're here today but thank you
thank you very much um so this started
off as a project that was intended to be
just for the third graders um knowing
that spiders are a little scary and
sketchy i didn't want to um
traumatize any young kindergartners or
anything like that so i thought i'd
break everybody in easy and just go with
third grade um but then as it kind of
expanded be a state spider event we
wanted to make sure that this was
something that our entire school got to
vote on
um we kind of took it as like we were
one big united states of our school and
every class got to have their own winner
and get all up together and we had to
count the votes so and it kind of
happened all along the same time so it
mirrored the election but was actually
it was great to have that kind of aspect
thrown into it as well so while we have
students from two different third grade
classes here
it did indeed go across the entire third
graders even our remote class at home
they had a lot of input as well and i
gave them a lot of at-home spiders
probably a lot of fighters living in
your basement addicts we found a lot
there
so uh everybody
so i i do have a question
the uh as you're well aware we're in
sort of covert protocols and everything
we do you are a school we are here at
the state house so one of the
experiences that
these types of bills that the school
classes usually bring is
they get to see it go through the
committee and they get to
you know tune in on the executive
session when we move the bill forward to
the house floor and
then they'll uh when it's on the house
floor they'll typically come and sit in
the gallery and get to you know be
recognized by the speaker and you know
sometimes we'll put an argument for and
against you know on on the bill just so
they can see the whole experience
obviously under our coveted protocols
we're not going to be able to do that
because we're not allowed to have any
guests into the into the house sessions
my question to you
is
we have an option as a committee to
retain a bill and hold it and
we could recommend it for passage later
in the year and it would come to the
house floor in january by then it's my
hope as i think it is with all of us
that we'll be back into our normal house
sessions in the
uh representatives hall and the children
would be able to attend and be in the
gallery now i recognize that that may
cause a problem because they may be in
another year of school and so i guess my
that's my question to you is if we were
to do that in the children i guess then
would be fourth graders would would they
still be involved and still be able to
come and enjoy the full process
you know of being in reps hall and
seeing the bill come to the floor
oh i feel like if this um that these
third graders they're pretty um set on
following this through even if it was
something that was turned down we're
just gonna try again as fourth graders
these guys are really really
bent on having a state spider so i feel
like and i'll follow them too our school
ends at third grade but this is
something that i will definitely help
them continue to work towards
well we certainly don't have to do that
it's an option my thought was getting
them the full experience of because
because really the true experience is
coming to reps hall it's it's
you know we we're one of the oldest
serving legislators in the same building
and it's it's just a real great
experience for all the children so that
was just a thought i had and i'm sorry
to see what works well for you guys you
know on your end as well
do we have any further questions we do
we still have a couple hands out but
representative verville has a question
yeah not so much a question is uh but a
statement so um thank you for the
presentation today you guys did a great
job you should be very proud of
yourselves and i just wanted to commend
you um i know i received emails from
many of you uh advocating in favor of
your bill
before the committee
met and uh that is always a very wise
thing to do and you guys were very smart
to send those emails in
to lay the groundwork for your for your
bill
i have a little bit of connection i used
to be a high school science teacher in
hollis at hollis brookline high school
and my wife used to be a spanish teacher
at hollis brookline high school so
it's nice to nice to see people from
hollis again anyway a great presentation
today and and thank you for the the time
thank you representative vervil
i'll recognize representative murray
hi thank you um mr chair and thank you
to the third grade class and to mrs
happy
i don't know who to address the question
to um but i did notice in your pdf slide
that the spider has very bright colors
at its face area and i was curious to
know um if there was a scientific reason
for that and if any of you uncovered
that in your studies as to why they're
colored that way
yeah
i know
so and and you're in you're correct in
noticing that so i do have a picture
right here they do have a kind of a blue
teal green iridescence you can kind of
see on his on those are his fangs
and that's kind of what sets this guy
apart from other jumping spiders and
that this is one of the key
identifications that you can do with
them and it just makes them look really
pretty to a girl spider so
kind of helps in that regard and they
dance a lot too
thank you very much and to the third
graders great job presenting you guys
presented your arguments very clearly so
i'm pleased to see that thank you very
much
any other questions
comments
all right well thank you guys you did a
excellent job and uh i think
we'll all give you a round of applause
if everyone is in does a wonderful job
[Applause]
this bill
next wednesday afternoon i believe
excuse me once our final bill is done my
estimate is it will be
at least three o'clock and maybe towards
four
uh if if you'd like to be in attendance
we can certainly try and get one of us
to reach out and connect with you as
we're getting close to the end of our
last hearing so you could sign on if
that's possible
what was the date chairman uh a week
from today i believe that's february 3rd
okay
all right um
i'm sorry chairman pearl can i can i
throw in one more thing is that is that
allowed can i do that absolutely go
ahead okay um just after thinking more
about
about all the hard work that these guys
have put into this and i'm looking at
their little faces behind their little
masks
they they could really use a win this
year they could really we we could l
we'd love to have a little spider party
have a reason to celebrate it's been a
rough year their whole world's upside
down they eat lunch in their classrooms
and it's just been kind of
so
as far as waiting i don't want to say
that i'm ungrateful for that opportunity
because i i would be and i'm i'm patient
and i try to teach kids about being
patient
but we could really use it when
the kids need this so if that's any if
that's any kind of
something to take into consideration i
just wanted to throw that out there real
quick
certainly thank you very much
all right seeing no other hands are
raised i will close the hearing on house
bill 318
and we will
take up our next bill in
three minutes which will be house bill
95 and we'll take that up at 2 45.
thank you for the reminder i believe
that
oh there was one everybody testified and
there was one name on the blue sheet
that was not in support but beyond that
everyone else that was on the sheet
testified thank you for the reminder i
keep forgetting to read that
those kids
all right seeing as it is 2 45 i'm going
to open house bill 95 a an act relative
to milk pasteurization and i will
call on representative allard to
introduce the bill
good afternoon
mr chairman can you hear me we can hear
you loud and clear uh
well before i launch into anything i i
must uh thank you for the opportunity to
pit my elegance uh my eloquence
against the
third graders from hollis
i'm sure i will be found wanting at the
end of this
mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for letting me introduce house
bill 95 for the record
i'm representative jim allard
representing
merrimack district 21 the towns of
pittsfield and epsom
and for many of you on the committee
this bill may appear familiar
and that is because you have seen it uh
once before
house bill 95 is identical uh in its
form and intent
to house bill
1234 which passed unanimously by your
committee
last session and subsequently passed on
the consent calendar in the house
unfortunately it was one more victim of
colbit
and so
we're having to take it up again
in a nutshell
what house bill 95 seeks to do is open
wider the doors of opportunity for
farmers in new hampshire specifically by
adding ice cream to the list of approved
products that may be made with raw milk
it is a bipartisan bill and has been
from its inception
it is coordinated with stakeholders at
the department of health and human
services very specifically the food
safety folks
as well as the farm bureau and the
personal involvement of the commissioner
of agriculture
i certainly hope that you can support
this initiative and i am ready to take
any questions that you may have for me
thank you mr chairman
thank you representative allard i'll
make one note uh for many of the
committee members there's one section of
this bill that
we'll need to edit that got in from a
different copy of last year
and that is the part that says we need
to remove the part that says or any
other product containing raw milk
because that created some issues and uh
we'll we'll certainly draft an amendment
as a committee and i've spoken with
representative
i'll allow him to confirm that he's uh
also
in agreement with removing that language
uh yes indeed sir
thank you
all right are there any questions for
representative alert
see you here
i do not see any hands raised so
we got one
okay he's not on the committee so all
right
representative thank you and uh we will
uh appreciate your testimony
thank you very much
next i will call representative woodcock
thank you mr chairman uh hopefully you
can hear me as well we can
i was one of the co-sponsors with
representative allen last year
uh particularly
let me first tell you that i represent
conway chatham and eaton
which all have multiple small family
farms
and the goat
ice cream issue became relevant to me
as it did gym last year we both have
small family farms in our
in our representative area that have an
excess of goat milk and the opportunity
to use that for revenue particularly
these last couple of years is uh been
critical to them
so on my side of the state uh a couple
came approached me at the same time as
representative alex uh issue uh of the
opportunity to provide
an additional revenue resource for them
during their slow summer months
and
find a reasonable
way to get rid of the excess goat milk
that they have versus just dumping it
um and i mean they already use it for
milk products they always use it for go
for salt products but those things but
this is a small niche area it's small
farms it's off their land
and it would be a real revenue help as a
bridge to get them through the summers
um so i'm here in support of the bill as
i was last year in support of the the
especially two goat farms in the
my area that uh look forward to uh and
honestly we're disappointed last year we
got hit by that final uh
bill uh problem at the end wanted wanted
to inadvertently go out and get excited
and purchase the
mechanical device to help with it so
they still are uh hoping this year that
this revenue bridge can be approved by
the york committee and as well as the
house and move forward so that they have
a chance to continue with the small
family farms which are as you all know
very difficult to maintain and
turn a profit
i'll be happy to take any questions
thank you
thank you representative are there any
questions for representative woodcart
[Music]
all right thank you i don't see thank
you sir appreciate it
welcome
next i will call on jill fudala
she's representing herself she is
actually a little history for those who
aren't here she is um
was sort of the main reason this bill
was was drafted was she was selling some
ice cream and
and uh
she ran into a situation where the law
didn't permit her to do it so
representative allen drafted the statute
last year statute change and uh
so jill why don't you take it from there
sure can you hear me yes we can okay
perfect um
well first just thank you for allowing
me to be here again and and uh tell the
story once again uh
as we've already already touched on um
kovid
affected a lot of things including ice
cream apparently
um
so
just um to
piggyback on what representative pearl
was saying um
that is basically the gist of what
happened we had been selling our raw
goat milk ice cream um and chuck metcalf
had brought it to our attention that
that really wasn't uh okay under the
current law and he suggested we try to
change it so um here we are and um as
representative allard had said
this went through the the committee no
problem last year with a couple
adjustments as far as adding i believe
um representative pearl and i had
chatted about adding a size limitation
on the containers and uh certainly an
expiration date which was no problem um
and um
and then
you know here
here we are having to go through all
this again
um but
the uh
what
representative woodcock was talking
about with the the revenue you know
being a small farm for us that was a
pretty big impact you know we we sold
about a hundred of these little six
ounce cups a week
which you know ends up for us being
about 300 a week into our farm which
isn't a big number but when you're a
little farm like we are that adds up um
for sure so
it was definitely a loss for us um and i
can relate to uh representative
woodcock's farm that he was talking
about where last year you know we were
so sure that this was going to go
through everybody was kind of on the
same page we worked very closely with
sean jasper and um dhhs and and the farm
bureau to make sure the language was
right in this and we were so sure that
we of course had our custom ice cream
labels made and bought an ice cream
freezer for our farm stand and we were
ready to rock so it was definitely a
a sort of a kick in the stomach when
that didn't happen
um but anyway here we are and um
i'm confident that you know that we'll
um succeed this time
um so
really i mean i i emailed
my testimony to all of you so everybody
should have it um you know i don't think
we need to go through and i'm not gonna
read it to you but i mean basically um
it is a revenue thing as a small farmer
and and um being able to have that extra
product really makes a big difference
for us um and it i i think that you know
we probably
um exhausted
last time talking about you know how
this doesn't ice cream certainly doesn't
pose any more health risks than any of
the other products that are already
allowed under the current raw milk law
um so you know it seems
seems like a a no-brainer to just change
the verbiage and and speaking of the
verbiage i want to just say too i'm 100
on board with removing that all you know
i think it says like any other product
containing raw milk that was not the
intention i think that was the original
um
draft when we started this journey a
long time ago and then together with
dhhs and and sean jasper and everybody
involved we changed that and paired it
down to just adding ice cream and i'm
i'm totally on board with that i have no
objection to that
um
you know i think that
i think that's really probably all i
need to say today i'm i'm more than
happy to take any questions if anyone
has any questions for me in particular
well thank you for the testimony are
there any questions for jill
all right looks like you're off the hook
easy so thank you
thank you very much howard
all right next up we'll call on robert
johnson from the new hampshire farm
bureau
can you hear me now we got you thanks
rob
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee good afternoon again for the
record my name is rob johnson and i
represent the new hampshire farm bureau
as a federation's policy director and
just to give us particularly the new
members just a little bit a little bit
more background on this when this when
the bill was introduced it was obviously
something that we had an interest in uh
miss fedular is a member
and and and all and and uh so we we
convened a meeting at farm bureau and
this would have been it was just a fall
prior to the to the previous bill's
introduction and at that meeting we had
folks from the from hhs the food
protection division
we had the the supervisor of the dairy
sanitation program that's chuck metcalf
who misfidula mentioned earlier
we obviously we had
representative allard as as the prime
sponsor and we had represent aaron as as
one of the co-sponsors
uh john porter was there john is the as
a long time extension dairy specialist
commissioner jasper was there
and we also had our president dennis
ward who was a retired dairy farmer and
very familiar with with the industry
and
farm bureau's concern again was as the
bill was introduced initially it had
that language that we're you're talking
about
of uh adding or any other
uh
product um
our dairy our dairy farmers are
commercial farmers they have a huge
investment in their operations and
they have concerns with uh if we if this
raw milk statute were wide open where
there could be any any reasons for the
public to doubt uh uh our milk supply so
we're
uh we're we're comfortable with this
edition
um
uh one thing that that miss fedular
didn't get into but she has a background
in the in the health field she does
things the right way she and and so it
was a it was kind of an easy and easy
call for us
um
so again i i urge for full support with
the removal of that language and i'd be
happy to answer any questions
thank you rob are there any questions
for rob
i don't see any hands up but
i don't see any hands up on the
committee
okay
all right rob i think uh we are all set
representative pearl
and uh i'll recognize jill fidell and
his additional performance
yeah i'm sorry i just wanted to add it
you know thank you rob for mentioning
that um
that piece i did put that in the
testimony that i emailed to everybody i
actually outlined
our process and how stringent it is as
far as
handling the milk and also
our process for milking and our cleaning
of everything and
that's actually something we really
really take a lot of pride in and it's
something that we've actually offered
our community
we allow other small goat herds to come
here and see our process we have a
three-based stainless steel sink down
here that we we wash we work with roy
glines to get all of our chemicals for
cleaning
we take that very very seriously i'm a
nurse so i understand
that
you know there are risks involved and
how important it is to make sure that
we're handling the raw milk carefully
and um
you know again we're hoping to actually
be holding some workshops for other
small dairies to really learn the ins
and outs of how to make sure they're
can't you know keeping that raw milk
safe and that is something that's very
important to us i thank you rob for uh
mentioning that
thank you jill
is there anyone else that would like to
testify on this bill if so when you're
on uh
on zoom just please raise your hand so
that i can see you
up colleen smith has her hand up can we
ring colleen
good afternoon members of the committee
thank you mr chair for allowing me to
speak today um
i did provide or abby rogers from our
department had provided my testimony in
advance of this bill um so this will be
sent to you if you don't have it already
we would just like to
go on the record that as the bill is
currently presented we we are opposed we
would like to see that language removed
as previously stated about the other raw
milk products we had worked very closely
with the sponsor in the past session to
limit that to just ice cream or frozen
yogurt um and we have concerns if again
if this was expanded to allow all raw
milk products in particular
soft cheeses that are made with raw milk
have been linked to several outbreaks
with e coli listeria in in recent years
just important to note that
certainly there is a risk
consuming raw milk for for foodborne
illness
our data in new hampshire shows that
over the past several years we have seen
an increase in foodborne illness that
has
food raw milk mentioned in their food
history
so that is a concern
and we want to also acknowledge that
while the current law allows for
raw milk to be sold at retail
under certain
certain quantities in certain locations
is that there isn't currently a
registration process for producers to
register or disclose on-farm or on-farm
sales and as
mrs fadalla mentioned
there are some best practices that
should be considered and the department
would certainly support and see value in
requiring raw milk producers to attend
educational programs on food safety
should funding be available so
folks can learn
best practices such as she incorporates
on her farm
that would be definitely something
as as other stakeholders i believe would
be in support of as well
and i would be happy to take any
questions and also want to acknowledge
that mr chuck metcalf from our dairy
program is also on the line if there are
detailed questions about the regulatory
process for dairy farms and dairy plants
in the state
thank you colleen are there any
questions
all right thank you i don't see any
questions appreciate your testimony
is there anyone else that would like to
testify if so please raise your hand
all right i don't see any raised hands
so i'll remember to read the blue sheet
this time we have seven other members
that uh signed in in support
all right with that being done i'm going
to close the hearing on house bill
95 and we will take up house bill 73 in
13 minutes at 3 15.
it was easier
do
researcher on the research
oh
[Music]
because he calls him on his phone
research
oh
um
all right it is 3 15 so we are going to
open the hearing on house bill 73
relative to public notice requirements
for certain permits issued by the
department of environmental services
and i will call on representative aaron
to introduce the bill
[Music]
okay good afternoon everyone
i'm representative judy aaron i
represent sullivan county district seven
ackward coast and langdon lobster and
washington
so i'm presenting this build again today
because this was one of the bills that
ended up in an omnibus senate bill
that
got
killed last turn
this was passed through our committee
unanimously and then
also went through the senate and it's
basically very very simple
to update it what this uh stat what this
uh proposed legislation does
is update our statutes having to do with
noticing requirements by the department
of environmental service
to include electronic noticing with
regard to giving the public timely
information about solid waste management
permits
it provides a wider opportunity for
public participation in significant
permitting decisions with potentially
long-term impacts on host communities
so
not everybody reads the newspapers these
days but they do
pay attention to websites and they can
access them from their electronic
devices
and apparently at this time the minimum
requirements and des rules
don't reflect the change in how public
accesses information
so it's time to update the statutes to
include the way in which people are
getting their information
and i believe that currently des does
voluntarily post permitting notices on
its website but there's not as far as i
know a consistent practice spelled out
within agency procedures rules or
statutes
so with this addition to statute there
will be
and this will be to the benefit of new
hampshire citizens
so that's pretty much
all there is about this bill and uh
i am open to any questions thank you
thank you representative are there any
questions for representative aaron
this may be a record for the fastest
bill we've ever done
[Music]
anybody else that would like to testify
on this bill
if you're in the
audience please raise your hand
all right i see no hands
i will read the blue sheet we have
four members
reporting three in support and one
neutral
and i will close the hearing on house
bill 73
our next hearing will be at 3 45 which
will be house bill 199
so um just a question that's not related
to the bill howard do you have a sense
of um
when we're likely to be doing the execs
on these bills
i'll turn my mic back on sure
i have scheduled some executive
session work next week at the end of our
uh hearing schedule
uh the hearing schedule will be out in
the calendar but i've got the uh
the landfill bill for the afternoon
starting at one and i estimate that will
be two to three hours of testimony based
upon the amount of
testimony that we had last year when we
heard it
so as soon as that testimony is complete
we will be picking up checking on
most if not all hopefully all of these
bills that we heard today
as long as we're able to do it
so that that's the general plan
all right thank you you're welcome
any other committee questions while we
have a few minutes
i don't see any other hands all right
then we will uh
recess until 3 45.
because
i cut wood so i'm outside all day by
thank you
this
oh
um
so
all right cena's is 3 45 i'm going to
open the hearing on house bill 199 an
act including soil health and soil
conservation in the state soil
conservation plan
and i will call on representative bixty
to introduce the bill
thank you mr chairman for the record i'm
representing peter bixby from stratfor
district 17
dover and somersworth
and
ranking member of the
house environment and agriculture
committee
so
this bill was voted otpa by our
committee
and by the house last year after
representative pearl and roger noonan of
the new hampshire farmers new england
farmers union worked out mutually
agreeable language it was then tabled in
the senate
and
what i have done is simply
taken the version that was tabled in the
senate and resubmitted it
um so a little bit of
uh i just wanted i wanted to cover what
for those who weren't here last year i i
want to cover
a bit of history and what the bill does
and doesn't do
first of all what the bill does not do
this bill does not tell farmers what to
do
and it also does not impose new
requirements on the soil conservation
districts
uh that being said i'd just like to go
back to um give a little bit of history
about where soil conservation districts
came from and
how we've ended up here so
back in the 1930s
as a result of
severe drought and
problematic farming practices
there was a massive wind erosion event
called the dust bowl
clouds of dust traveled
from as far as oklahoma to
washington dc where they blocked out the
sun in dc
the federal government figured out that
this was a problem and they required
states to create uh state soil
conservation plans and they also created
the soil conservation service which was
later renamed to the natural resources
conservation service or nrcs and you
have probably seen reference to nrcs
grants over the years
so soil conservation districts are
essentially the working arm of the state
soil plan
and they provide
education and technical assistance to
farmers and to landowners
the last revision of the
new hampshire soil conservation plan
took place in 1985 uh with some minor
changes in 1995 and at that point
uh it was essentially bringing the idea
of um
making making sure that uh soil
conservation was done in a way to
minimize impact on waterways
uh
and
uh in the 1980s one of the main focuses
of soil science was the physical soil
structure and the and soil nutrient
chemistry
uh since that time especially since
around 2000
a lot more attention has been paid to
soil biological activity and soil
organic matter
and
the understanding of how
the microorganisms in soil
profoundly affect the nutrient
capacities of the soil the
nutrient-holding ability of soil the
water holding the soil
holding ability of soil and the general
resilience of soil
have really
changed the way that we understand how
we need to work with soils
and how we need to
particularly work with soils to
improve that biological activity
and the term that
has been given to resilient soils with a
lot of biological activity
is healthy soils
a lot of the work on this came out of
the ag ag school at cornell university
but it's all it's something that is
being broadly
investigated throughout the country and
it is something that
a lot of major agricultural producers
are also really starting to pay
attention to
so what the bill does is it brings the
science in the state soil conservation
plan up to date
to include
soil that the term soil health and
related concepts
it also recognizes the good work that
our soil conservation districts are
already doing uh related to soil health
so
uh
a lot of the work that
many soil conservation districts in new
hampshire are doing at this point uh
involves things like
helping farmers with cover cropping
providing
low-cost rental for equipment such as
aeration equipment seed drills
and
cover crop crimpers
uh
and because
these pieces of require of equipment are
expensive and
only get used two or three times a year
at most
uh by having a a rental pool of them in
the county it means that a lot of small
landowners and farmers can take
advantage of them without that capital
expense
and uh so uh another so
um so we're basically recognizing that
they are already working on these things
and uh it should be recognized in what
is essentially their charter uh
document which is this the state soil
statute
the other thing uh another key thing
this bill will do is it will provide
language
essentially in their in the statute
that they can point to and say
when we're applying for this grant
we are fulfilling the
the requirements of um the state
statutes and
the state is behind us on on uh in this
project and
that makes for much stronger grant
application uh and which brings me to
another topic which is you know
how are soil conservation districts
funded
they are largely
um
one part of their co of their funding
comes from
the uh
what the counties decide to give them
each county
has a soil conservation
district line in this budget
and
the what the counties provide is
generally the fundamental support for
staff and administrative costs
uh in terms of
the projects the education and technical
assistance projects that they do
they the districts generally
apply for grants in order to get the
money to do that and uh the more
the better the more and better grants
they can get the more they can do for
our farmers
so
a lot of the the nrcs is one of the main
granting agencies
but
with a broader interest in soil
soil health
that is
becoming apparent throughout the
um
multination the the
farming community across the country
organ organizations like cargill general
mills walden family foundation
foundation for food and agriculture
research these organizations have taken
an interest in soil health
and uh they
are probably
uh establishing grants that would
be
that our conservation districts could
apply for
uh having this language in this statute
uh will
strengthen their case um
so
on the
um the key
uh the core ideas in this bill are
providing a definition of soil health
and providing some uh
information
some guiding ideas about the benefits of
soil health and
since
the person who
did the primary drafting of this
language uh was roger noonan of the
um
new england farmers union who is
also a small farmer himself has been uh
and are a certified organic farmer for
years
uh i will
turn more of the explanation of the bill
over to him uh if
i'd be willing to take questions but in
many cases i might just bump those
questions to roger
thank you
are there any questions for
representative bixby or i might suggest
honestly that we hold off and let uh mr
noon into his testimony and then we'll
ask questions of both if that's okay
sure
but
i'm going to call up roger noonan from
the new england farmers union
uh thank you chairman pearl
and ranking member bixby members of the
committee
i'm roger noonan i'm a small family
farmer in new boston new hampshire
hillsborough county
served as a president of the new england
farmer's union farm bureau member nofa
new hampshire member member of more
things and i can shake a stick at a
former conservation district supervisor
in hillsborough county
we worked with nofa new hampshire and a
couple of other uh stakeholders in
looking at ways to address some of the
challenges that we were seeing relative
to climate change and extreme weather
events
uh i think any of you that are involved
in agriculture know we had a we had a
drought last year and we had another
drought in 2016 we
we can get too much rain in the same
year we're not having enough rain
uh there's a lot of challenges and when
you're a small farm as peter pointed out
you know some of this these
this equipment you know you really can't
justify the cost of purchasing some of
this stuff when you're only running 10
20 30 40 acres you know
so the fact that we can share this
equipment amongst a bunch of uh
farms in the county is is a real
multiplier for us
more importantly i think what as peter
also laid out this is just an update of
the bill you know this started out with
a dust bowl addressing soil loss
from erosion wind and water erosion then
in the 80s
it was addressing some water quality
issues
uh soil health sort of pulls all of the
above together into a into a broad
bucket now that we're recognizing that
the soil is
where it all starts
um and we've got to maintain good
quality soil
and the other uh
and the other part is the adaptation and
mitigation of a change in climate and
adaptation is probably the most
important thing for those of us in new
hampshire we don't i don't i mean there
may be some farms and especially some of
our dairy farms that can get into
digesters and that'll have some there'll
be some mitigation uh opportunities
there where they can get paid for
sequester and carbon in different ways
but for a lot of our small farms that's
probably not going to be a real uh
goal but adapting you know providing uh
improving our soil health our practices
to make our land more resilient to
excess moisture or
these extreme droughts um that's the the
real crux of this uh bill
uh it provides it's just providing
explicit statutory language uh to allow
for these things and peter made another
great point about grant writing when if
anyone's been involved in non-profits
when you put in for a grant you know the
the key thing that most funders look at
would you be doing this anyway are you
just putting in for this because there's
a lot of money out in the uh
the grant a sphere
for that particular action so this
provides explicit language
to um
help our conservation districts get out
there and get the the public and the
private money to help our small farms
cope with this work thanks and i'll be
happy to take any
questions you roger uh representative
aaron has a question for you
thank you so much for your testimony
today and uh i appreciate
uh help our conservation districts but
i'm curious to know a little bit more
i see the definition of soil health in
this
in this language here
but i'm interested to know is is there
more
to
soil health and so far as
um
more measurable
statistics of
uh
you know how much organic matter and the
holding capacity of the soil and so
forth and if so do do you look at that
or
is that looked at
uh
from an average standpoint throughout
the state or in specific areas of the
state i mean
our soil health is different from
you know town to town district to
district
so
how is this
how does this help
so the the definition of soil health
care is sort of a broad one
as as anyone that's that's involved in
natural resources
we know that you know there's a lot of
specificity related to any particular
site uh i've got fields even small
fields 10 acres or less that i can go i
can probably find three or four
different very radically different soil
types you know glacial till to sandy
stuff down by the riverbank and you know
heavy clay a little clay patch where we
used to make bricks a couple hundred
years ago uh so it doesn't really
address it's not
a soil typology as opposed to a set of
conditions
um
that
that indicate good soil health you know
you want you know you want good
permeability
organic matter and that's going to be
real you know
organic matter is
you know some soils will have higher
organic matter than others naturally and
others will be depleted either through
human or other interventions as well so
it's not um
this isn't sort of a thing where you say
this is good soil health and and here's
your you know here's your merit badge
for your good soil health and there's
one standard that fits all but it's sort
of a set of parameters that many
different soil types can fit into
i can also pick up a little bit on that
cornell university has actually come up
with a
broad set of different soil
characteristics
including things like cation exchange
capacity organic matter content
and the organic matter content divided
into several different categories of
organic matter
uh and
different nutrient holding capacities
levels of
humic and
fulvic acid
uh
and they have
made a very broad panel of all of these
characteristics and
you can send your soil a soil test
sample off to cornell and they will give
you a very
detailed
analysis of what the soil health looks
like i think another element of that
might also be the the types of
microorganisms found
and and fungi found within the soil uh
so
uh there are uh actually
um sort of physically
measurable uh parameters for this and
beyond what i've just told you uh it's a
little bit out of my pay grade
okay well thank you i appreciate that
all right thank you both uh
representative hamola has a question
thank you mr noonan for coming in and uh
and presenting this to us today i'm i'm
actually very interested in this i'm a
natural hazard mitigation planner in my
day job and i've actually had my hand in
statement mitigation plans so i
appreciate the enormity of this uh the
one i have two questions the first
question is on page two
on definition
definition for this that's more
generally
um universally accepted in this
definition is a little bit more tailored
and i'm just wondering if this
definition is tailored specifically
so that
the state plan has a
kind of a better chance at getting
grants
so i i'm i'm sorry representative um i
did not uh you were a little
sort of soft i couldn't quite hear you
um
page two the definition of which
thank you can you hear me better now
very well thank you thank you so much um
i was saying that i'm actually a hazard
mitigation planner my day job and so i
appreciate the um what you're trying to
do here very much uh page two on the
bill
was giving the definitions of things and
it gave a definition for mitigation that
is is not a generally universally
accepted definition of mitigation it's a
more tailored version and i'm just
wondering if that was by design to allow
the um the agency to apply to grants
that are more tailored towards climate
change
um well i would defer to your
professional experience on on broader
terms of mitigation but
this one we basically lifted from the
u.s department of agriculture's natural
resource conservation service
in so far as it applies
you know to those things that they're
working on and have been working on um
in
you know since the uh the boy shoot i
think this original definition was
developed uh under uh the previous
iteration of secretary vilsack's term um
that's been the working definition i'm
involved with some national groups
um that are working with industry
partners and these are sort of the
the terms that were being used okay
thank you and um the second question i
had is there anything in the state plan
currently that prohibits a discussion on
climate change
well uh
that's a great question i
would like to see the state plan i don't
i don't know that i've ever seen one
so
okay i just i'm asking the reason i'm
asking is just because i'm trying to
understand i know that when i i do plans
there's the the plan writer has the
ability to write
whatever it is that needs to be to cover
how they want to talk about
um talk about the subject and it's not
there's nothing that prevents it so i'm
just wondering
maybe what the need is to add that
language in if unless it it's sort of to
remove some prevention that that climate
change can't be talked about it i know
when i when i work on uh i've worked on
a state plan in oklahoma we absolutely
had the freedom to include it if we
wanted to or not include that if we
didn't want to so i'm just kind of
wondering if you knew anything about the
state plan in that regard right so in
terms of the
the term the state soil uh conservation
plan this statute act is effectively
that plan
so uh and it was the this is the plan
that was ordered that the federal
government ordered states to have back
in the 1930s and
uh the progression the sort of
gradual progression of
minor changes to the plan
uh has um
has gone on since then uh and i as i
mentioned earlier the last significant
change was back in the 1980s
uh and
the um
the reason so there's nothing in this in
this statute that says anything about
climate change whatsoever
uh and so and there's no sort of state
prohibition on saying anything about it
it's
the the main thrust here is that
a lot of the grants that
are now
likely to become available
uh in response to current world
conditions
may make reference to climate change and
the having that as a specific
[Music]
goal of our state soil conservation plan
is something that uh would strengthen
any grant that we that someone from a
conservation district would write
and
thereby increase the the chances of
getting it
thank you sir
thank you representative i'll remind the
representative that
the all questions should be directed
through the chair rather than having a
conversation
that's all right
all right do we have any other questions
for uh
uh representative stapleton
uh thank you uh mr chair thank you for
taking my question
i'm having difficulty with uh page 2
line 22
roman two
um
the mitigation um
of course i've not heard of this before
um or seen this kind of thing before but
are we really focused on the sources or
the effects
of climate change
and and preventing um damage or harm
from those
effects rather than perhaps trying to
change climate and reverse climate
and i'm going to give you an example
where i'm asking this
we've noticed in the past couple of
years
torrential rains
much heavier than we typically
have been used to in decades past
to the extent that they're washing out
roads so
to
mitigate the effect of that
towns and cities are increasing the size
and the expense and the expanse of rip
rap
so that it prevents the war road warship
um
and and the the other part of this that
confuses me is
the words enhance the sinks
of greenhouse gases
i i'm not in that industry uh are
familiar with that can you explain that
enhance the sinks of greenhouse gases
what you're driving at it is that for
me or mr bixby
i'm sorry
i guess who i would like to answer it oh
i'm fine with taking it so in the in the
context
of
of agriculture
and that's that that's where that's my
foundation here uh
what you described relative to a town
in the agricultural sense would be an
adaptation it's not that we're not
trying to
modify or do things that uh
reduce
the conditions that are making these
extreme weather events happen reducing
greenhouse gases now sometimes
adaptation practices
are
this are similar or the same as
mitigation practices but i'll give you
an example of mitigation practice and
that's why i said this
is probably limited to only our largest
farms because right now there is uh
there are existing markets for carbon
sequestration in ag soils also in forest
soils and so what when an industry say
cargill says
we're going to pay farmers to sequester
carbon and the farmers are going to
adopt no-till practices or put cover
crops on and then they're going to get
you know 15 to 20 per acre for the
carbon that they sequester after it's
you know measured and quantified
the that's what the mitigation uh is
addressing and to reduce the sources or
enhance the sinks and greenhouse gases
you know if you re if you every time you
till the soil you're releasing carbon
into the atmosphere
so the more that you can keep that
carbon in the soil
that is a mitigating effect and there
are other things like i mentioned
digesters for our larger dairy farms may
prove to be something that will
provide
power revenue power revenue for the farm
as well as perhaps a mitigating carbon
uh payment as well um
but again
given the smallness of our agriculture
in general mitigation is is not uh
uh probably the the first and foremost
thing it's really those adaptive things
representative like you mentioned about
what the town's doing to deal with you
know 100 year storms every 20 years or
whatever the frequency is we're having
them now
is that does that answer your question
sir
it begins to draw my attention to where
i have to go to learn a little bit more
about this these are strange terms but
that that is helpful thank you for the
answer you're welcome thank you for the
question
all right any other questions
representative control
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um i remember this bill from last term
and we discussed a lot about climate
change and then at the time i don't
believe the term technology
environmental change was in there
and we had suggested taking climate
change and putting in environmental
change because and i'm just trying to
wonder why we have both now in there i
think you said because of grants but i
just want to double check on that
representative bixby i think
so uh
the
uh
there was a lot of discussion about this
in terms and and
essentially
that phrasing of um
the uh client
the climate ending uh climate and
environmental change was a
uh
language that i i believe that that
might have been what was negotiated
between
uh chairman
pearl and uh roger noonan uh
in order to
sort of um iron out some differences in
language preference uh the
in terms of um
the importance of keeping the climate
there is
definitely that that will strengthen uh
the
um
the ability for
districts to get grants uh the
um having the environmental change in
there as well
is an indication that uh soil health
doesn't
there are other environmental
environmental changes that may be
happening
that are not strictly climate related
that soil health would also help
offset or
re or
adapt to
and mr chairman if i could just sort of
tag on to that uh just a couple of
examples you know invasive insects
uh and those are coming in from changing
weather patterns they're they come in on
shipping crates uh you know so we're
getting uh invasive species all kinds
insects plants there's a there's a wide
range of new challenges uh that we're
facing you know on the landscape
thank you uh representative murray has
her hand up did i recognize her for a
question
thank you mr chair thanks for
recognizing my question uh mr noonan i
did have a question
uh i guess regarding terminology as well
i was thinking about the terminology
that i've heard called regenerative
soils is that similar to anything we're
talking about i'm just trying to come up
to speed myself
so regenerative is um
it's the new sustainable uh a few years
ago sustainable was the the term du jour
uh for all things that were uh
not
what we currently do and now it's
regenerative so regenerative includes
things like
no-till with gmo crops and and
you know spraying glyphosate because
you're not tilling the soil so therefore
that's for general organic farming like
i practice is regenerative because we
use cover crops and incorporate green
manures so it's a it's a broad catch-all
term it has
uh
varying definitions i think uh that
whatever company monsanto is part of now
since uh has a has a regenerative ag
terminology right down to you know you
can find it on most organic
companies websites so
but it generally refers to those same
things you're going to improve your soil
health you're going to store carbon in
the soil you're going to reduce tillage
those those are sort of foundational
practices they're foundational practices
to the soil conservation movement uh
going back to the to the 1940s
thank you
all right any further questions i don't
see any more hands any representation
yes
we'll give you one more
sorry
so sorry i'm learning all this right now
um i did have a question hopefully you
can hear me now or if not i'll jump up
but
the question i did have is on page 4
line 22 just
in sentence for landowners
can you uh
can you speak to what what's inferred on
incentives
sure so i'll give you i'll give you a
personal example a couple of years ago
somebody from the conservation district
pulled up with a pickup truck and handed
me four bags of cover crop seed uh you
know that's an incentive for me to put
cover crops in my ground um
uh their other incentives could be
i mean that's
i think that's a prime example and
really what i think we're trying to do
here
you know we've got a federal agency nrcs
that does a great job working with
farmers helping them put these practices
on the ground but
if any of you folks have worked with
them you know they're for a smaller farm
they can kind of have a high bar of
participation there's paperwork and
a lot of things that a small farmer
especially one that may be farming
part-time uh may find
that the juice isn't worth the squeeze
so the more we can empower our
conservation districts
uh just to get those funds from wherever
to do this work i think the the more
we're gonna have small farmers
be able to adopt these practices and try
them out and see if there is a economic
return and
and i'll tell you an
economic return would be i'll tell you
last year we had a drought but you know
we we had a pretty we had a pretty good
crop because we've got high organic
matter we're able to hold our soil we're
using the drip irrigation we're doing
those things um
that help us adapt uh to the
increasingly unpredictable
weather and i know those of us that
lived in new england a long time know
that it's always been unpredictable but
i've seen two
major droughts in the last four years
and that would had not seen any prior
and i'm 59 years old so
uh we are seeing we've seen rain events
too so
uh incentives include just
getting the tools we need uh that we
want to try some of the cutting edge
stuff um
uh which you know i you know we farm
about 30 acres i'd be hard-pressed to
spend ten thousand dollars on a piece of
equipment i'm going to use twice a year
to to till a multi-species cover crop or
a roller crimper or some of these other
things so
thank you so much thank you
thank you any uh further questions
representative murray did you have
another question your hand is still up
no i did not sorry that's okay
anybody else
all right thank you both uh
representative bixby and roger noonan
appreciate your testimony thank you
folks
is there anybody else
to testify on this bill
so when you're in the listening audience
please raise your hand so we can see you
all right i do not see any hands
so i will read the blue sheet
we have 10 people signing in uh eight in
support one opposed and one neutral
all right that completes uh
our hearing on uh
hb 199
and that completes our hearings for
today
i thank you all to the committee you've
all done a great job enduring the
several hours we've been here and
we will be
having hearings again next thursday
excuse me next wednesday february 3rd
beginning at 9 00 am
and we will have another full day of
hearings followed by an exec session
well thank you all that joined us and
have a great rest of your evening
thank you you too bye-bye thanks